Prince William of Wales and Kate Middleton are to be married.
When I first met Kate, I knew there was something very special about her...
...and I knew there was possibly something that I wanted to explore that...
...but we ended up being friends for a while and that was a good sort of foundation.
And I'm obviously extremely funny and she loves that...
...so it's pretty good.
We did come to a hockey game at one point when we were at Marlborough...
...and she said, "I'd love to become a princess one day."
"I'd love to marry Prince William."
And obviously after Marlborough, she went to university.
And she said that she met this really nice boy.
She said, "boy."
I said, "Right?"
I said, "What's his name?"
And she said, "Um, Willie."
"Willie? So, all right, he sounds nice."
And she did say that he was absolutely lovely and she said she thinks she might have fallen in love.
I think that they are going to be the most solid royal couple we've had since the Queen and Prince Philip.
I definitely think so.
They are completely in love, dedicated to each other.
They mesh well together, they work well together,...
...and I think they both have the same personalities.